point de pas fait trop pour la deè fois
en 2 jours Nicolas sarzi a provoqué le
scandale à l'Assemblée nationale et le
départ des députés socialistes de
[Applaudissements]
l'hémicycle un flottement inhabituel du
quelques minutes plus tôt à une question
un peu vicieuse d'un élu socialiste à
propos du voyage de Nicolas SAR aux
États-Unis est-ce qu'un peu plus de
modestie ou à tout le moins de lucidité
nurait pas abouti à un peu moins de
succès personnel pour votre expédition
mais à un peu plus de grandeur et de
cohérence pour la France réponse du
tacotac du ministre d'État il s'en prend
à Daniel vaant qui selon lui n'aurait
rien fait pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme quand il était ministre
de l'Intérieur parceès 5 années du
gouvernement de Monsieur Jospin on était
arrivé à faire croire autats-unis
d'Amérique que la France
éta
colère des socialistes qui lèvent le
camp Ilic presto et s'en viennent
protester auprès des
journalistes il faut pas se laisser
impressionner par Sarkozi qui est un
petit politicien sectaire
méchant je crois qu'aujourd'hui il a
donné il a donner son vrai visage au
français c'est-à-dire quelqu'un de très
intolérant de provocateur je crois
aujourd'hui que effectivement Nicolas
Sarkozi parce qu'il est pressé trop
pressé de prendre la place de je ne sais
qui à je ne sais quel moment est-ce
celle du Premier ministre est- celle du
président de l'UMP ou est celle du
président de la République qu'il utilise
des arguments qui le déshonorent lui les
amis de Nicolas Sarkozi auront senti le
danger ils tenteront de minimiser
l'incident mais après les menaces qu'il
aurait proféré hier à l'encontre d'Henry
Emmanuelli il y a bien ce soir une
affaire
Sarkozi